today's sponsor is blue Chu and they're
giving you your first shipment totally
free all you have to do is pay five
dollars for shipping go to blue chewed
comm use promo code David I've put the
link right underneath this video so
we've been waiting for it and it's
happening Donald Trump is now publicly
saying he believes that foreign
countries he won't say which ones will
be rigging the upcoming presidential
election against him
this is particularly funny to use a word
that really lightens the situation it's
really tragic but it's sort of funny for
Trump to predict that other countries
will rigged the election against him
since he has repeatedly said he would
consider accepting help from other
countries and according to John Bolton
even asked China for help but I'm
getting ahead of myself
let's let's wait for a moment because
there's a few stories here first is that
in general Donald Trump has appeared to
be particularly on tilt over the last
few weeks on tilt is a term from chess
and poker sometimes from other games
where when you take a bad beat you make
a mistake or you appear to get unlucky
or you make an error then it influences
your future behavior and you behave even
more erratically during future games and
moments and that seems to be got what's
going on with Donald Trump yet his
failed rally on Saturday in Tulsa
Oklahoma slumping into the White House
with a tan stained white shirt out of
his helicopter on late Saturday night
reportedly yelling at his staff for the
lack of turnout we covered it all
yesterday meanwhile he sees that polling
is not looking so good and now Donald
Trump is loudly and wildly proclaiming
that foreign countries are going to rig
the election against him and this is
another instance of Donald Trump maybe
we don't really know what he's doing and
it may not even be a you know a
thought-out strategy but he may be
laying the groundwork to contest the
results of the election in the future
when he loses he could argue he didn't
really lose because it was rigged and
he's been talking about it being rigged
and priming his followers to believe it
will be rigged for months
Trump writing yesterday on Twitter quote
but this is all caps by the way I'm not
going to
do anything in my reading to reflect
that it's all caps just know that it's
all caps rigged 2020 election millions
of mail-in ballots will be printed by
foreign countries and others it will be
the scandal of our times then tweeting
minutes later because of all caps
mail-in ballots 2020 will be the most
rigged capital e election in our
nation's history no apostrophe on
nations unless this stupidity is ended
we voted during World War one and World
War two with no problem
but now they are using Co vyd in order
to cheat by using mailings that's the
president by the way that's not some
conspiracy theorist who's like a third
string or Alex Jones tweeting that
that's the President of the United
States at least for a few more months so
remember he spent the last three and a
half years arguing that an election he
won was rigged against him so of course
he's going to say that it was rigged if
indeed he loses and this is a
particularly unhinged claim foreign
countries are going to print ballots and
what fill them in and send them to local
polling precincts like what's funny
about this is that Trump knows so little
about how voting works that he seems to
think this could be an actual thing that
could be done like Trump has been on
this unhinged crusade against
vote-by-mail for a couple of months now
saying it leads to fraud and so on and
so forth here he says the fraud would be
foreign countries would print massive
numbers of ballots all I guess perfectly
formatted to match the format of any
particular precinct fill them in as
votes for Biden and then send them by
mail now absentee ballots as you may
know are only sent to registered voters
like if you send in a thousand ballots
saying Oh Joe Smith voted for Biden and
Nancy Smith voted for Biden and Joe
Smith jr. voted for Biden and Joe Smith
the third like when they're received
they're checked against a registered
voter list in that precinct if that
person isn't actually registered to vote
in that precinct then the ballot is
thrown out
if the person already submitted a ballot
then another one coming in with their
same name is going to be thrown out and
not counted this would be an insanely
stupid way to try to steal an election
and then by the way so layer one is
Trump is until layer two is this is a
dumb way to steal an election number
three is it's particularly stunning that
Trump is decrying foreign interference
because you might remember that in an
interview with George Stephanopoulos he
was actually asked you know if Russia
offered help dirt so to speak if China
offered it would you accept it and Trump
said that he might let me remind you
about that interview from a few months
back this is somebody that said we have
information on your opponent oh let me
call the FBI give me a break
life doesn't work the other director
says that's what should happen the FBI
director is wrong your campaign this
time around a foreigners if Russia if
China if someone else offers you
information on opponents should they
accept it or should they call the FBI I
think maybe you do both I think you
might want to listen I don't there's
nothing wrong with listening if somebody
called from a country Norway we have
information on your opponent oh I think
I'd want to hear you want that kind of
interference in our elections it's not
an interference they have information I
think I'd take it if I thought there was
something wrong I go maybe to the FBI if
I thought there was something wrong but
when somebody comes up with a poor
research right they come up with a poor
research oh let's call the FBI the FBI
doesn't have enough agents to take care
of it but you go and talk honestly to
congressmen they all do it they always
have and that's the way it is it's
called Oppo research
now the reason Trump is doing this is
very clear he's seen the polls and he's
scared you know publicly he claims every
poll is fake if it says that he's losing
even when it's a Fox News poll even when
it's a Rasmussen poll but privately
we've heard reports that Trump is
absolutely furious with his staff he
doesn't understand how he's losing so
badly Fox News had Biden ahead by 12
last Thursday Quinnipiac had Biden ahead
by 8 CNBC has Biden +10 economist has
Biden up nine new poll out of New
Hampshire says Biden his plus
that was tied almost in 2016 Paul says
Biden plus seven there's a Florida poll
that says Biden plus seven I I find that
a little bit hard to believe but then a
tip poll has Biden plus eleven in
Florida it's insane as the point and we
all have to vote but clearly Donald
Trump is triggered by the polling so now
we'll wait and see what happens in
November but the important thing to
address here is that if Donald Trump
thinks foreign countries are going to
rig the election against him why hasn't
he done anything about it if it was
rigged in 2016 against Trump and he
believes it'll be rigged in 2020 against
him why is it that for the last
three-and-a-half years despite numerous
attempts from mostly Democrats to
actually toughen up and harden our
election systems so they are not subject
to foreign interference why has Trump
opposed all of those measures why is
miss Mitch McConnell opposed all of
those measures and ideas that have been
put forward it's because any good story
needs an enemy and here the enemy is
so-called foreign votes mail and boats
double voting etc etc it's not real and
the final sort of insanity and hypocrisy
here is once again that this is
something that Trump allegedly went out
and solicited according to John Bolton
it's not just what Trump said to George
Stephanopoulos well if they sent it to
me I'd look at it it's actually the
allegation is that Trump went to the
Chinese president and said listen I need
farmers to help get me reelected in
November of 2020 can you start buying
more stuff from our farmers to help me
get reelected it's not just he would be
willing to accept it it's he allegedly
went out and solicited it and that's
what makes this all so so insane now
let's talk about the next level of crazy
which is Donald Trump coming out against
the First Amendment here in the United
States I didn't even get a chance to
talk about this yesterday but it's
absolutely baffling and disgusting at
his rally on Saturday night Donald Trump
came out violently against the first
amendment to the cons
of the United States Donald Trump said
in Tulsa on Saturday night that by the
way stop emailing me saying it's I know
it's Tulsa yeah come on we're just
having a good time
Trump said on Saturday night that he
wants flag-burning
to be punishable by a year in prison
despite the fact that the Supreme Court
has said multiple times flag burning is
a protected activity you can't punish
people for burning a flag it's a type of
speech check it out check out Donald
Trump's audience cheering for this
supposed constitutional conservatives
cheering for the attempted destruction
of the First Amendment by their Dear
Leader who they will of course
unquestioningly vote for in November
take a look two days ago leftist
radicals in Portland Oregon ripped down
a statue of George Washington
and wrapped it in an American flag and
set the American flag on fire
[Applause]
Democrat damn all democratic everything
I tell you is Democrat and you know we
ought to do something mister senators we
have two great senators we ought to come
up with legislation that if you burned
the American flag you go to jail for one
year one year
the crowd not even hesitating I mean so
again so-called conservatives who
support the Constitution cheering for
Trump suggesting we punish a
constitutionally protected activity with
a year in prison now it's also important
that this I want to focus on the flag
burning but there's also a deliberate
conflation that Trump does Trump starts
by talking about tearing down a statue
but then he says burning the flag should
be punishable by a year in prison
tearing down a statue can be a property
crime right that's it that's a very
different thing than constitutionally
protected speech burning a flag stomping
on a flag that is not only not a crime
it's specifically protected activity
it's a form of speech protected by the
First Amendment and this is not an
obscure legal decision like this is wide
legal precedent widely known legal
precedent the Supreme Court decided in
1989 in Texas v Johnson and it
reaffirmed it in 1990 in US v eichman or
Eichmann that any prohibitions on
so-called desecration of flags are
unconstitutional it's just flat-out
unconstitutional burning a flag as a
form of speech it's symbolic speech
burning American flags is a form of
speech in protest movements that go back
a long time
so what Trump is asking for and what his
audience is ravenously cheering for it
is unconstitutional will his followers
care that Trump is proposing something
unconstitutional no mostly they won't
you've got actual principled
constitutional conservatives now when I
say principled I don't mean I agree with
their views but what I mean is they
don't abandon their principles when
Trump says the opposite and then cheer
it the way people in the crowd are doing
they are sometimes coming out like
George Will has come out and said he's
got to go Trump's got to go I don't
really agree with George will on most
things but George will at least abides
by the principles he has identified as
being important to him and that includes
that what's in the Constitution
at least as he sees it matters now it's
important I think to mention there are
limitations on flag-burning like you
can't go on to a neighbor's property and
drop a burning flag on their wooden
porch right but that's not the flag
burning that's illegal there it's the
trespassing and the arson whether you
drop you know papers or a burning flat
if anything if you do that there are
other crimes you are committing but
that's not what we're talking about here
we're talking about just the burning of
a flag Trump kept going calling for
exactly the type of legislation that the
Supreme Court has already said multiple
times is unconstitutional take a look we
should have legislation that if somebody
wants to burn the American flag and
stomp on it but just burn it they go to
jail for one year okay this is what I
call dumb red meat we talk about red
meat and dog whistles in in American
politics and and Republicans very often
throw them out this is dumb red meat and
Trump has actually been using this dumb
red meat for a long time here's just one
video of Trump from 2016 you'll notice
by the way sounding far more articulate
saying something similar about
flag-burning
two people ripping up the American flag
like that flag beautiful when I see I
think it's a disgrace okay and you can
say what you want free speech it's all
wonderful everything's wonder if I'm a
big believer in free speech but maybe
we're going to be putting something in
to see if we can do something about it
because this is a special case and when
I see people burning the American flag
and then stepping on it as it's burning
up and then stomping on it and stepping
on it on the ground I don't think I
don't think in the I don't think I
remember that when I was going to set
right how many of you guys are young
like me remember when we were very young
I don't remember that happening yeah so
dumb red meat it fires people up but it
also sort of confuses them since they
thought they were for free speech and
that they were for the Constitution I
guess they thought Trump was also for
those things and then Trump comes out
with a year in prison for burning the
flag so on
first and I guess the takeaway is first
of all this didn't get nearly enough
attention this is the president saying
cancel the First Amendment at least the
part of it that he doesn't like but
understand how backwards things are that
we have a White House that dropped the
ball on coronavirus Trump admitted he
wanted to reduce testing early on so
that he would look better
we have protests against vile police
brutality we have nearly 20% real
unemployment rate and the controversies
that Trump wants to focus on are do
people kneel during the anthem or not
and did somebody burn a flag it's not
just transparent it's actually pathetic
because as I said yesterday he has no
case he has no coherent case for why he
should be re-elected and so he's talking
about flag burning and kneeling during
protests kneeling during the kneeling
during the national anthem in sports as
well
it's fully authoritarian it's also
really dumb and hopefully this country
is never in a place where flag burning
seriously has a chance at becoming
criminalized even under the relatively
conservative Supreme Court that we have
right now I don't see any way that
there's any shot at flag burning being
criminalized as it should be let me know
your thoughts I am on Twitter at D
Pakman remember that you can subscribe
free to the daily david pakman show
audio podcast it's the earliest if you
look at all the things we publish
Facebook clips YouTube clips etc the
earliest thing to publish is the daily
audio podcast which is available for
free on iTunes stitcher google play
pandora iheartradio Spreaker pod bean
spotify as you can tell it's too
available at this point really the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
[Music]
this episode was sponsored by blue Chu
giving my viewers their first shipment
totally free when you go to blue to calm
and use promo code David it's just a
reality that many men regardless of age
can sometimes benefit from a boost in
confidence a little bit of performance
help blue chew is the first chewable
tablet with the same fda-approved
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis blue to
being a chewable tablet means it starts
working twice as fast as a pill it's
prescribed online you spend a couple
minutes with a short questionnaire a
licensed doctor reviews the information
decides if a prescription is right for
you it's then shipped directly to your
home in discreet packaging no awkward
visits to the doctor's office or
pharmacy plus it's also cheaper than
getting it at a pharmacy when you go to
blue chewed calm and use promo code
David you will get your first shipment
completely free just pay five dollars
shipping that's promo code David to get
your first shipment of blue to
completely free and I've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com ok today's new members of the
day are robbing hell 3 and carl Haglund
you may never have heard of membership i
know it comes up so infrequently on the
program but we're mostly funded by
members membership just means you go to
join pakman.com and you sign up it's
quick it's easy you get the daily
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show as well as the world-famous
award-winning only Awards we give out
but still award-winning bonus show we're
producer Pat joins me to discuss more of
the news of the day grab a membership at
join pakman.com stay a member and you
may someday be the longtime sustaining
member of the day today that's Natasha
Glover who's been with us almost five
years in news that will surprise
absolutely no one but yet is still being
miss reported somehow we now have eight
Trump staffers who attended the Trump
rally in Tulsa on Saturday or who were
there that day some of them were
actually sent home early because they
got the virus who have tested positive
for coronavirus remember that on
Saturday we learned that six Trump
staffers tested positive for coronavirus
Trump was furious that the news got out
that they had tested positive we now got
a new statement from the Trump campaign
which says that quote after another
round of testing for campaign staff in
Tulsa two additional members of the
advanced team tested positive for the
corona virus these staff members
attended the rally but were wearing
masks during the entire event upon the
positive tests the campaign immediately
activated established quarantine and
contact tracing protocols so in the
midst of all of this two Secret Service
agents also tested positive for corona
virus so we have to clarify the
misinformation we've been dealing with
this virus now for what four months that
we know of in reality even that we knew
about even longer in reality and you're
immediately seeing every nonsense
reaction that you can imagine from Trump
estándar people on the right to this
news so first of all this line about the
last two staffers got the virus even
though they wore
masks during the entire event this is
causing some people to say
see look masks don't even do anything
masks do work we have a new study that
says the faster countries obtained
widespread numbers of masks the faster
they suppress the spread of coronavirus
also remember that the rally didn't
require masks so whether masks do or
don't work which they do the rally goers
weren't wearing masks but the most
important element of confusion is that
nobody is saying any of these staffers
caught the virus at the rally in fact
six of the aid staffers who were tested
positive were part of the adventure they
were all part of the advance team but
six of them left before the rally even
started in other words clearly they got
the virus sometime last week incubated
it for you know 48 hours a few days and
then tested positive on Saturday and
were sent home these other two staffers
we have no reason to believe that they
actually caught this at the rally not to
mention they could have caught it in
Tulsa but not at the rally where they
were wearing masks and instead somewhere
else we have something called an
incubation period so right away this is
bad news right that this is more proof
the rally shouldn't have happened
because the rally didn't require people
to wear masks and you have these low
information trumpets who say this is
proof you don't even need masks because
they don't work no that's that's not the
right story that's not the right story
at all now what we should be seeing as
the take away from news that eight Trump
staffers plus two Secret Service agents
caught the virus around the time of the
rally is that the rally was a really bad
idea
with 6,200 people there plus countless
staff and law enforcement and others
what are the odds that these eight
people were the only people in the place
with the virus that day let's grant that
these eight didn't catch it at the rally
because I don't think they did there are
obviously other people who were there
that day who also were incubating the
virus and they had caught it elsewhere
and nobody was required to
we're masks now that being said no
method is 100% foolproof right masks are
useful if everybody's wearing them that
dramatically reduces the chance of
spread but it's just a numbers game if
you put 6,200 people indoors even if
they all wear masks someone is likely to
catch the virus through one of those
less likely contagion methods we've
learned over the last few months surface
contagion is not that common right early
on there was a lot about sanitizing and
bleaching your vegetables and food and
boxes that you know take out all of this
stuff turns out that the surface
contagion is actually quite quite rare
but if you have 6,200 people together
you can have a one in six thousand
incident and that still means someone
catches the virus through a surface
contact someone takes their mask off for
a second and sneezes on a door handle
someone 15 seconds later
opens the door and then has to adjust
their masks and touches their eyes and
there you've got it right even a very
unlikely event when you have sixty two
hundred people together becomes far more
likely this is where the rules come from
or guidelines come from about it's
better if you're not in groups of more
than ten why because with fewer than ten
people a one in a thousand contagion net
that is very unlikely to happen with
6,200 people a one in a thousand
contagion contagion method or risk is
likely to now have six instances of
contagion I think that most of you sort
of understand the math when will we know
the effect of the Rallye on cases in
Oklahoma we may never know we have to
understand that because unless we get
contact tracing news because cases are
exploding in general in Oklahoma we may
never really know the effect of that one
rally as you can see in Oklahoma we're
putting a case chart up on the screen
the cases were already spiking from the
day before the rally and they've
continued a spike it takes about 10 to
14 days to know the full effect of
contagion from any particular event so
we may never really know because cases
are spiking in Oklahoma in general now
some good news from here in
Massachusetts we had the protests
against police brutality two weeks ago
all
everybody was wearing masks and
massachusetts numbers continued to
improve so what we are learning again is
the masks do work which we knew already
and that is reassuring to say the least
cornered rats start to behave really
erratically and that's what we're seeing
right now with the president as
questions continue to grow about Donald
Trump's mental and physical health as
his polling continues to collapse as the
world continues to point and laugh at
him as coronavirus tragically rages and
kills people in the US despite many
countries having it completely under
control
Donald Trump has now wildly and without
evidence accused former President Barack
Obama of treason
now we've seen Trump now for a while go
on about Obama supposed crimes
remember Trump talked for a while about
Hillary Clinton's supposed crimes that
seems to have been forgotten and Trump
even said not long ago that Barack Obama
committed the greatest political crime
in American history but when he was
asked specifically what was that crime
he had nothing that was then he has said
now in an interview that err yesterday
with the Christian Broadcasting Network
yeah that the crime is treason let's
take a look here is a visibly sweaty and
disheveled Trump casually saying the
crime is treason the crime that Barack
Obama committed is treason also the
interviewer David Brody really makes me
cringe with his little interjections you
can tell Brody is one of these suck-ups
that just is desperate to be Trump's
friend here's Trump accusing Barack
Obama of treason on Obama and the spine
situation is this idea that they were
spying on your campaign you've been
asked before about what crime he would
have potentially committed but I
remember you talking to treason
it's treason look look when I came out a
long time ago I said they've been spying
on my campaign I said they've been
taping and that was in quotes meaning a
modern-day version of taping it's all
the same thing but a modern-day version
but they've been spying on my campaign I
told you that a long time ago turned out
I was right let's see what happens to
him now
Durham is I never meant to her because I
want to stay out of it because otherwise
it's gonna look political let Durham as
you know is a highly respected person
and Bill Barr is doing a great job as
Attorney General
let's see what they come up with but
they don't have to tell me all I have to
do is read the papers the insurance
policy in case she doesn't win
we got a insurance policy well that was
all the stuff that we went through over
the last let's say two and a half years
now we caught him we caught him called
struck and paged the two lovers Brennan
and clapper the way they lie Democrats
can't stand behold me they just they
can't see in his bill bar they just
think he's pulling you know why because
he's doing such a good job because he's
law and order but he's got him in his
crosshairs and now we have to see what's
going to happen I will say this if it
were reversed and if the other side said
we're at The Oval Office right in that
chair behind the resolute desk and it
was the opposite two years ago 25 people
would have been convicted and they would
be sent to jail for 50 years so I want
to remind you we are experiencing hyper
normalization so I I have to state
unequivocally this is not normal a
president accusing a former president of
treason is not normal and it is
outrageous
Trump has possibly just months left in
his presidency hopefully and he is
focused on let's see what William Bar
comes up with on treason by Obama and
the Obama administration now just to
give you a little context treason laws
in the United States exist at the
federal level there's also state treason
laws the definitions are pretty similar
in most states the treason statutes are
similar to federal law and it's about
levying war against the United States
helping the enemies of the United States
giving aid or comfort to enemies of the
United States only 30 people in history
have been charged federally with treason
under those
extremely rare it's wild it's wacky it's
embarrassing for Trump to say it about
Barack Obama they never actually had the
goods and this is a continued sign of
desperation now I want to remind you
here is what Trump said when he was
asked by The Washington Post's Philip
Rucker this was it was either three
years or three weeks ago it's hard to
tell right now know that I think this
was during the last four to six weeks
Philip Rucker asked Trump when you talk
about Obama gate what crime are you
alleging was committed and Donald Trump
says come on Philip you know what it is
take a look mr. president in one of your
Mother's Day tweets you appear to accuse
president obama of the biggest political
crime in american history by far those
were your words
what crime exactly are you accusing
president obama of committing and do you
believe the Justice Department should
prosecute him Obama game it's been going
on for a long time it's been going on
from before I even got elected and it's
a disgrace that it happened and if you
look at what's gone on and if you look
at now all of this information that's
being released and from what I
understand that's only the beginning
some terrible things happened and it
should never be allowed to happen in our
country again and you'll be seeing
what's going on over the next over the
coming weeks but and I wish you'd write
honestly about it but unfortunately you
choose not to do so yeah gently I'm what
if the crime exactly thank you you know
what the crime is the crime is very
obvious to everybody what you have to do
is read the newspapers except yours a
true classic moment of the Trump
administration it's really really
terrible that it happened right but mr.
president what is it that happened you
know what it is you know what it is I
guess now Trump is saying that what
happened is treason so now that we've
got the sort of facts out of the way
let's take a step back because I do
think there's an important element of
hypocrisy 2.2 here and hypocrisy no
longer matters to the American right
maybe it never did as President Donald
Trump has insisted time and again he can
do whatever he wants he can say whatever
he wants to whoever he can do whatever
he wants he can't be investigated these
have been the positions of the Trump
administration Trump's entire presidency
has been based on the president can do
whatever the hell the president wants
period it's sort of a
a version of Nixon's if the president
does it it's not a crime on steroids so
if that's the case couldn't Barack Obama
have done whatever he wanted while he
was president how is it that Trump can
do whatever he wants and can't even be
investigated but William bar can be
investigating Obama for treason now what
Trump might argue is well I'm a sitting
president Obama is no longer president
except Trump has previously argued this
never should have even been allowed to
happen while Obama was president and
Trump of course believes he shouldn't be
investigated after being president four
things he did while president so it's
complete and total hypocrisy now my
question to you it's I researched this
today couldn't find any examples has any
president in modern American political
history accused a former president of
treason I wasn't able to find any
examples I'm asking you for help if
other presidents have done this please
let me know and we will be covering this
extensively on the shows Instagram at
David Pakman show
also make sure you're following me on
Instagram at David Pakman if you want a
break from the politics I have a picture
of myself holding a teeny-tiny puppy
over the weekend it's on my Instagram at
David Pakman it's a beautiful message of
peace lovin and understanding in tough
times or it's just a funny picture of a
puppy you be the judge
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the
world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 welcome back
to the David Pakman show
it's great to welcome to the program
today Jerry Mitchell whose stories have
helped put four Klansmen and a serial
killer behind bars
there's that's an introduction aching
for more detail Jerry so I appreciate
the opportunity to talk to you so tell
us a little bit about your investigative
work and you you wrote the book race
against time which tells the story of Ku
Klux Klan murders that went unpunished
during the civil rights movement talk a
little bit about how you got into this
space and how this all developed pretty
close proximity
the first being I happen to see the
movie Mississippi Burning which is a
fictional film about the killings of the
three young men the civil rights workers
killed at a Klan in Mississippi James
Chaney and you given into making shorter
and they were killed on the first day of
summer in 1964 which was also part of
Freedom Summer which was very important
to the civil rights movement in terms of
college students coming down and give it
to one of those uh but they're basically
nobody
the thing is shot I mean watching a film
and I happen to be sitting by the FBI
agent by the way who investigated the
case which is another Wild Thing in
retrospect
but I was shocked to discover more than
20 Klansmen revolt in that killing and
nobody ever been prosecuted for murder
that was the part I just couldn't wrap
my head around
David artists was that common I mean in
there going back however far back
want to go how common was it that the
perpetrator was in lynchings etc were
just never prosecuted extremely common
but I was woefully ignorant and I you
know this was all news to me at the time
in 1989 and so you know I grew up on my
little you know white bread world and
East Texas and I didn't know any of this
and you know and so here I had plopped
in Mississippi in this new job and
anyway it's all news to me and and I'm
just a lowly reporter and just you know
stumble across this and so I started
reporting about that and about the same
time I find out about this I don't know
if you're like me but if someone tells
me I can't have something I want it like
a million times worse right so there was
something Mississippi called the
Mississippi sovereignty which was the
state segregation spy agency and there
were like a hundred thirty-two thousand
pages of records that the Mississippi
legislature sealed for 50 years one of
them so when I found that out my first
thought was well there's something in
there you know don't be stealing for 50
years otherwise so I had developed
sources to begin to leave me the files
and what they showed was at the same
time the state of Mississippi was
prosecuted Barney little Beckwith for
murdering Megara versus other Norman
state's sovereignty Commission was
secretly assisting the defense trying to
get back with acquitted and nobody do
that and so my story ran October 1st 89
and that's you know basically the case
gallery oh that's kind of the short and
when it comes to I mean so there's a few
cases that you've worked on so-called
cold cases that you've started
researching on and researching and
reporting on at what point during these
what is the step that makes it so that
it is officially reopened and being
reinvestigated that kind of opens the
door once again right well the case of
the major case it was this revelation
and helped to kind of probe and then by
the end it kind of one thing
let's another Myrlie Evers that's what
the case be reopened the newspaper the
Clarion Ledger where I was working
editorial lines for the City Council
voted for it and in basically the DA's
office by the end of the month said he
was reopening the case but it really
didn't kind of tie begin to turn until
months later when discovery of that
Beckwith had bragged to a Klansman about
killing Medgar Evers and so that kind of
began to turn the tide it was
technically reopened but didn't anything
was gonna happen and that's really what
did so when you start investigating some
of these cases what type of
investigative work are you doing are you
are you saying who can I talk to are you
interviewing witnesses is it a lot of
data and research work yeah we're like
for example I was able to get a copy of
the transcript
Myrlie Evers had shared and widowed
Medgar Evers and so that was really
helpful I went and interviewed the
police officers for example and gave
back with an alibi and they their story
differed from what they one of them
differed from what he had told back in
64 in the trials now those officers even
agree to talk to you years ago for my
Herald pretty much white or lighter it
said well I look like Opie you know so I
mean I think I came across this kind of
a horrible sky you know in their eyes I
certainly saw them so anyway welcome and
at different points as these cases start
to shift from being unlikely to ever you
know having a resolution to hey were
this is being looked into to hey there
there could be charges coming do you
worry about your personal safety she was
concerned I was going to be killed and
respect I understand a little better
than I did at the time you know which
she was here I'm going to interview the
killer mega rivers and she was eight
eight eight months pregnant with her son
so yeah you know I didn't take it really
into account but but speaking of
Beckworth I went in the interview and
and so yeah there were some frightening
moments I when I when I interviewed
Beckwith I spent about six hours with
him
absolutely this most racist person ever
spent time with and it was six hours
later it's dark he insist on walking me
out to the car and I'm like really
that's okay for the car he says if you
ride positive things about white
Caucasian Christians God will bless you
if you write negative things about why
Caucasian Christians God will punish you
God does not punish you directly several
individuals will do it for him right I
was going to say if it was just going to
be left to God that's one thing but he's
making it clear that that maybe yeah
so I mean I have so many different
aspects of things that I want to ask
about but in in your investigation in
some of these conversations you know one
of the interesting things that at least
today is not often told about the
history of the civil rights movement the
Mississippi Burning cases it is an
interesting example is that there were a
lot of Jewish folks who were working
with the civil rights movement and in
fact sometimes the victims including in
Mississippi Burning are presumed to be
black Americans but are Jewish folks did
you in your work on these cases also
encounter that anti-semitism was just
completely wrapped up with the anti
black racism he was really almost really
more any semitic than he was
any black anything wasn't white pretty
much but he was a part of what's called
christian identity and he bec was is not
alone on that
the head of the clan was also believed
this and Christian identity is
essentially just a horrible racist you
know religion and they believe that
Avenue for white people they believe
that all the other non-white races or
mud people quote unquote they're like
animals and I'm Souls and and then they
believe I mean this is where it gets
really rank and horribly racist toward
the Jews they believe the Jews are
literal offspring of Satan right no you
know what's interesting about hearing
you say mud people I think it was more
than ten years ago I interviewed this
guy named Glenn Miller who says since
has been arrested of course for killing
people he believed were Jewish but in
fact were not and I I asked him uh you
know in from your perspective is is the
real threat the black folks or the
Jewish folks and it was sort of like
hard for him to even say like there was
just a lot of it's not even clear he had
it straight but they were all mud people
that's the exact word that he used this
is a common term of Christian identity
and that's what they believe it's you
know they believe that white people are
the true Israelites it just gets very
strange and you know I mean following
the logic of it there's not really logic
but yes you are correct they believe mud
people and and very anti-semitic I mean
there's a really good book on other
several good books we could point to you
but blood in the face
James Ridgeway Road which talks about in
fact they brought that term up to me
that's why they believe it's white
people because white people can blush
and then and then there's a book Jack
Nelson wrote some years ago called
terror in the night which is about
basically the Klan in Mississippi were
originally attacking African Americans
as well as white sympathizers but then
they really shifted their focus to
attacking the Jews they began to bomb
synagogues Bob Jewish
homes and things like that for any of
the Klansmen
blindsided by charges in other words was
while you were working on stuff did
people start to get a catch wind of what
was going Li nervous okay and or stop
talking to me at certain points you know
my idea was to get in there early I
wanted to talk to the killers I wanted
to hear what they had to say and and
keep them talking it and their just
because just at certain points I know we
had actually because Beckwith stopped
talking to me but we had another
reporter who went and actually was
sitting there almost right right when
Beckwith he got a call and basically he
was gonna get arrested and he was like
they sent a reporter away and Beckwith
us and Beckwith and his wife or fuming
and yeah so it's it's fascinating you
know to hear all this as it unfolds I
think that there will be people who
listen to our conversation and they will
maybe envision that the era you were
investigating was a different era where
things you know people don't get away
with murder in the same way now that
they did then but in fact in some parts
of the country the murder resolution
rate is actually quite low and there's a
lot of good research about this there's
you know some more specific ideas about
vehicular homicide being a pretty safe
way to kill someone if you want to
murder them that's kind of a more niche
topic but generally speaking it's not
like murders are overwhelmingly being
solved today isn't it you know smart you
know look carried out by people who you
know maybe they're angry at the time and
and you know there they are the police
catch them with blood on their hands yes
what I'm saying is most homicides are
relatively easy to solve you know I mean
but you're right about the murder
resolution rate in terms of the
that are better that are different more
difficult to solve you're right the raid
is not what you would love to like to
see because in other words like if you
have any intelligence about it it's
almost easier to get away with murder if
that makes any sense we're going to uh
we're gonna go to a break on the
broadcast show but we're gonna continue
our conversation with Jerry Mitchell
which you can find in full over over on
our youtube channel the david pakman
show at david pakman.com the david
pakman show depends on the support of
our viewers and listeners and one way to
keep us going is through patreon where
you can pledge as little as one dollar
per month or as much as you want at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about him the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
okay I want to have a conversation with
you today in order to maybe focus some
of our economic critiques right now and
make sure that we're not missing the
forest for the trees I think is the
metaphor that that makes the most sense
now if you like this type of segment I
would love to hear from you about it if
this is not the type of analysis that
you find interesting I'm also glad to
hear from you here's my thought we're
increasingly seeing individuals like
Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates maligned not
just as bad people personally but as
emblematic of the problem as people
sometimes like to say the problem with
our economy in the United States and
there's a lot that I can find to
criticize about the way that Jeff Bezos
built Amazon and the way that Bill Gates
built Microsoft but I believe that the
focus on these types of tech
entrepreneurs is really not the lowest
hanging fruit that we should be focusing
on in order to fix our economy so I'll
set it up for you and then and then we
can kind of talk through it Bill Gates
created Microsoft Jeff Bezos created
Amazon they've both become obscenely
wealthy personally wealthier than
anybody needs to be their taxes at the
individual level are certainly too low
they should be paying more in taxes they
regularly take advantage of a lack of
regulation which has allowed their
businesses to be more profitable by the
way as an aside I mean Bill Gates at
this point is not even involved with
Microsoft he's just a philanthropist so
it's kind of backwards looking in terms
of Gates but the analysis is still the
same one
so are there criticisms about Bill Gates
and Jeff Bezos in terms of their
businesses of course I mean look at
Amazon Amazon working conditions aren't
good in many warehouses they should be
paying employees more in many cases a
lot of the products they sell are
manufactured with sweatshop labor in
other countries etc etc Bill Gates and
Microsoft took huge advantage of weak
antitrust law in the United States
during the 90s I believe it was you can
search YouTube for some of the
depositions to learn more about that and
there's other criticisms but compared to
what I believe should be the real
targets in order to strengthen and
improve our economy
Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates really just
shouldn't be the focus and they're not
the evil doers so to speak that some
make them out to be Amazon is a huge
company that employs a crazy number of
people they've created so many jobs
should working conditions be improved
should some of them be getting paid more
are there problems with how Amazon uses
uses third-party contractors for
deliveries and uses that to avoid
liability of course of course and I'm
right there with you but consider the
good that Amazon has done during the
pandemic people are able to safely get
the things that they need without
leaving their houses people who live in
rural areas and they want to start a
business where in their immediate area
it's tough to get the products they need
to start that business Amazon can ship
the stuff to them they've allowed
countless small businesses to sell
products and be profitable Microsoft
created Windows which became arguably
the catalyst for the personal computing
revolution on which can we say millions
of tens of millions of jobs are now
based in the information industry so if
you want to argue that regulation should
be more strict on these companies that
Microsoft should have been broken up
that Jeff Bezos doesn't donate enough
money to charity or that he's richer
than anyone should ever be I'm right
there with you but let me suggest that
the focus may be should be elsewhere
now first of all a lot of what people
are criticizing about Jeff Bezos and
Bill Gates is not really about Jeff
Bezos and Bill Gates
it's about policy so focusing on them is
actually the wrong Avenue while we
continue to elect a lot of the same
people that won't really change anything
but most importantly the focus should be
on the elements of our economy that are
completely unproductive and I would
argue predatory there's criticisms of
Microsoft and Amazon but they also have
done so much good in revolutionizing the
world in positive ways look at the bail
industrial complex
what is that industry achieve that is
productive other than making money off
of people in the criminal justice system
what is payday lending achieving other
than skimming
obscene interest from people who can't
pay their bills what about the financial
instruments including derivatives
derivatives of the ribber
derivative derivatives derivatives of
derivatives etc collateralized loan
obligations none of this stuff really
adds to the economy the people making
money from these tools will say these
are legitimate ways to mitigate risk for
large corporations etc it's skimming
skimming skimming so that a small group
of people get rich off of big
corporations and rich people hedging
some of their risk debt collection
agencies the entire debt collection
industry even looking at high-frequency
trading within mutual funds so that the
traders and the fund managers earn huge
commissions while they deliver subpar
returns to customers that are investing
their life savings with them in the
financial space there are entire
categories of products that are not
productive for the economy they don't
deliver anything that can be used by
people to make a business or to make
anybody healthier these are entire
swathes of the economy that just enrich
the individuals who come up with and use
these mechanisms to extract money for
themselves so to go back to my main
point there is no question that there
are serious criticisms of our economy
which can be seen through the fact that
people like Jeff Bezos and Bill Gates
have achieved such obscene wealth and
when it comes to antitrust regulation
tack rate tax rates whatever else that's
a real conversation to having I don't
want to belittle it but Amazon's
existence is not where I would focus I
would focus on the entire industries
that exist only to leech and skim from
hardworking people for no benefit to the
broader economy
I believe that's what we should be
paying the most attention to and trying
to fix and I want to hear your thoughts
hey this is really funny just a little
bit of a break from the horrible news
you might enjoy this a bunch of people
in the audience have been writing to me
saying David you should make an account
on cammy oh okay
where people can sign up to have me send
people to shout out or try
somebody I got a bunch of Father's Day
requests from people saying hey please
send a shout-out to my dad or whoever
else they really like the show this is
all at cameo dot-com slash David Pakman
or you searched my name in the Cameo app
I got an absolutely hilarious request
from someone whose friend
I guess bought one of these online
charisma classes and paid $600 and his
friend was concerned so here's the
here's the message that I sent him take
a look at this hey Matt so I heard from
KC that you spent $600 on an online /
ESMA class now maybe you're very wealthy
and if that's the case that's fine but
in my experience you can find a lot of
that material for free and I would even
be glad for you to call in to my show
when I'm taking live calls and talk
about what I'm told is maybe a desire to
improve some dating skills okay so with
total peace and love if you want to
figure out a way to get on my show you
can email me through my website we'll
figure out your phone number so that we
take live calls I see your number pop up
we can talk about what's going on it's
free
no $600 for an online charisma class and
hopefully hopefully you'll come away
with something just as valuable okay so
I want to hear from you so I'm serious I
actually want to hear from Matt I hope
that he will call in I didn't realize
that people actually paid for online
charisma classes I guess I should have
realized that that because they've been
around for a while someone must be
paying for them but I would love to have
Matt call into the show we can talk
about what's going on but maybe the
funniest part about this is that someone
thought that I would be the right person
to go to for advice on charisma and
maybe dating which I don't know
something about that is actually even
funnier so now also I've gotten some
requests on cameo that I had to turn
down people trying to get me to say you
know anti-semitic stuff and all of this
other stuff so some are being
but it's a pretty fun platform you can
send me requests in the app I am David
Pakman on cameo or you can find me at
cameo comm slash David Pakman okay we
have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine two david p this voicemail
is a textbook example of strawman okay
take a listen to what this caller says
in response to my recent story about
coronavirus take a listen twice a day
here calling for fort lauderdale florida
watching your show the David Pakman show
right you left out a lot of information
a lot of it is not pragmatic or
realistic at all okay twenty thousand
people are not dying every day the
reports that you're looking at are
invested in by people who have a vested
interest of giving you false information
so remember what the caller says it's
twenty thousand people are not dying
every day let's continue you're using
that false information incorrectly it's
just shameful I live down here
I go back and forth to the beach every
day right but we're having a great time
they're enjoying their life
there's no sirens on a daily basis
letting us know that people are dying at
a massive aggressive rate okay you want
to talk with me and contact me I can
give you facts and proof in video feed
to show you what's actually going on
regardless of somebody who had some
money and fingers placed into an
investment of marketing the wrong idea
that you seem to support right so they
say David you're wrong twenty thousand
people aren't dying yeah I never said
twenty thousand people are dying I said
20,000 or 25,000 cases are being found
each day in the United States and that's
true so this is what's called the straw
man arguing against an argument I never
made David you're wrong that twenty
thousand people are dying never said
twenty thousand people are dying it says
there's no sirens in Florida letting us
know people are dying I never said there
were sirens in Florida letting us know
people were dying what I'm saying is we
have data available if anything the data
is understating the severity of the
problem so guys do not make straw man
arguments it looks bad it's not good
argue against what I say rather than
what you claim that I said we've got a
great bonus show for you today become a
member
to get instant access at join pakman.com
we will talk about an incredible story
from a hair salon about masks and
coronavirus and so so much more I will
see you on the bonus show if you are a
member if not I'll see you tomorrow
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's sponsor
blue chew is giving you your first
shipment completely free all you have to
do is pay five dollars shipping go to
blue to calm and use the promo code
david i've put a link right underneath
this video